normal que la publicité s'arrête alors
on va parler de pub avec vous puisque
vous évoquez avec moi la sortie d'un
livre intitulé le vertige des urnes
c'est le récit de toutes les campagnes
que vous avez menées en france et à
l'étranger pour faire élire des hommes
politiques l'ont et de françois
mitterrand à ehud barak en passant par
lionel jospin à chaque fois vous avez
imaginé des thèmes qui ont fait mouche
dans l'opinion rappelle avec thomas
dandois
c'est en mai 68 sur les murs de paris
que jacques séguéla à trouver la source
de son inspiration et le sens de la
formule choc un sens de la formule qui
servira françois mitterrand en 1981 avec
la force tranquille sept ans plus tard
le fils de pub remet son talent au
service de la gauche avec la fiche
génération mitterrand sans avoir jamais
rencontré dit il le président candidat
si vous voyez cette affiche dites moi si
vous n'aimez pas de graaf
en 1995 il rejoint lionel jospin en
cours de campagne présidentielle il lui
est fait alors abandonné le fond rose
contrôle vers et adopte le slogan
changer l'avenir puis il se tourne vers
l'international en israël son équipe
produit plusieurs clips pour ehud barak
dont un qui tourne en dérision benyamin
nétanyahou qui peut bien voter bynocchio
aujourd'hui l'enfant terrible de la pub
a des vues sur la russie et sur
l'algérie des pays où dit-il la
publicité doit devenir le sponsor de la
démocratie
jacques séguéla c'est vous à chaque fois
qu'ils choisissaient votre candidat
votre poulain non c'est comme dans les
mariages s'est jamais l'homme qui
choisit ses veulent c'est le candidat
qui m'appelle puis on peut pas sonner
aux portes en disant rouge vaudrait
faire votre campagne ça c'est un peu par
cooptation le téléphone de l'un à
l'autre ils vont finalement hikma il a
été pas mal et prend le vous dit
connaître la recette pour savoir à
l'avance le vainqueur d'une élection
alors si c'est vrai qui va gagner les
prochaines présidentielles c'est un peu
trop tôt mais je pourrais vous dire ça
six mois avant les campagnes argent ce
qu'on appelle un mapping politique sur
une carte sur laquelle on trace les flux
sauce culturel ses attentes souterraine
des français qui sont non pas encore
émergé mais qui vont tous donc à sourde
comme ça très vite et puis les qualités
des défauts j'allais dire des marques
des candidats en place si on voit
qu'elle est celui et pousser et qui va
vers les attentes de son peuple et quel
est celui qui rejetait alors vous avez
travaillé l'image de nombreux candidats
combien ont gagné grâce à vous un peu
grâce à vous on vient au 4 4 2 duo phare
gardienné niall blazy j'ai commis 14
campagnes ce sont toujours les cartes
d'électeur gagner et jamais moi et j'ai
eu la grande chance d'avoir 13 victoires
et la dernière celle dabo diouf qui est
une défaite avec un presque un goût de
miel dans la bouche parce que c'est
quand même la victoire de la démocratie
tout le monde disait que c'était
campagne africaine étaient truqués que
c'est toujours les mêmes qui restait
bien preuve par neuf non un président
depuis vingt ans peut-être battu par un
candidat démocrate car il nous donne
envie de croire qu'un homme politique
peut se vendre comme un produit normale
entre guillemets non d'abord que quand
on achète une lessive si elles lavent
pas plus blanc l'âge est non président
de la république on a là pour sept ans
donc on a mal tourné on a intérêt à
vérifier que vraiment ils lavent plus
blanc si on veut être cynique les
procédés sont les mêmes ça s'était mis
par une affiche par un spot de
télévision par par un slogan mais
peut-il avoir plus beau que l'aspiration
de la moitié d'un peuple petit avoir
plus beau qu'un homme qui pendant ses
temps de sa vie va porter le projet de
toute une nation que c'est pas
comparable mon métier à moi est le même
mais moi je ne suis que l'on parle
heures je suis la sono alors on peut
dire que sans les beatles sans le sou
noir un puck beatles mais enfin de
talence et des beatles s'est passé pas
les micros oui vous les aimez ces
candidats que vous accompagnez dans une
campagne présidentielle ou autre vous
allez me prendre pour un coeur
d'artichaut je tombe amoureux de je les
choisis toujours dans ma famille on
inspire que je refuse ce qui ne sont pas
démocrates ou ceux qui sont deux
d'extrême droite ou ceux qui qui ne vont
pas porter la modernité et puis c'est
comme ça je suis une sorte de
péripatéticienne de luxe tombe amoureux
fou puisse dieu de manga et je ne peux
pas oui fils de pub est jeune et je ne
peux pas je ne pourrais pas me mettre à
leur place et passionné pour eux comme
je le fais si je ne partageais pas le
heureusement mais c'est tous à peu près
les mêmes si le même profil ricardo
lagos dont je viens de finir la canche
lie au chili c'est françois mitterrand
c'est la même force tranquille barak
c'est jospin il ya des points de
rencontres extraordinaires vous dites
dans votre livre que vous avez inventé
le terme gauche plurielle et que vous
regrettez de ne pas avoir demandé de
droits d'auteur vous avez inventé comme
ça d'autres formules qui sont reprises
par les hommes politiques à fils de pub
qui a repris aussi parler la poudre de
riz oui parce que le une campagne
électorale c'est un moment de sociologie
à vif dont toute chose laisse des traces
c'est un moment où
les peuples mute profondément et donc si
on a la formule qui correspond à ce
moment là elle est portée ensuite par
l'histoire merci jacques séguéla césure
à la dge mario reste avec nous pour la
fin de ce jour là